Let's go next to our caller from the two one
eight area code. Who's calling today from
two one eight.
Hi David. It's bill.
Hey bill. What's up?
Oh, well it's cold. Hey listen. Um, what do
you think it's gonna take for us to, uh, really
honest to God? Get back to a normal to get
out of these dark ages that we're in right
now because you know, the elections, it seems
like that's just a bunch of bull. Uh, you
know, I don't know. Just what do you think
it's going to take? I don't, I'm not advocating
for a revolution, but I know that's out of
the question. But look like a change in consciousness.
People got to, I mean, isn't it time everybody
woke up and realized?
Yeah, very, very good. So listen, you neither.
It sounds like from what you're saying, you
are not like a revolutionary leftist. I am
also not what, what I would consider a revolutionary
leftist. I'm a social Democrat. So here's
the, here's the reality. I did a segment about
this a couple of weeks ago. It might feel
like a lot of our systems are unsustainable
and if you just draw a line from where we
are now, it seems like they would be medical
bankruptcy, education costs, inequality, it
seems unsustainable. The establishment has
a way of throwing a bone every once in a while
to keep people in this middle ground where
they are just okay enough that they're not
going to abandon their job to do the types
of activism that will really crippled the
financial system and force change, but still
also in a precarious enough position where
they also really can't afford to do that type
of protesting.
So like on healthcare, some bone can be thrown,
some people would argue Obamacare was a sort
of bone, whatever. So as I said before, signing
petitions is fine. Calling members of Congress
is fine. Voting is more than fine. You've
got to vote as a starting point. The system
is designed to prevent people from doing mass
rallies at urban centers. And I mean, not
just people who already live in the city.
I mean the state population, masses at the
Capitol, demanding change, strategic defaults
of mortgages, strategic call-outs to cripple
industry. I think that without becoming revolutionary
about it, unless and until we get Ted, that
type of activism, I think we will see more
of the same of working around the edges and
throwing a bone to people every once in a
while to basically maintain the status quo
for corporations and rich people.
I see. Yeah. I agree with you. You know, you
had a color a minute ago from Australia. I
know there's a country you, the total country's
on fire and he's done. They're saying, I can't
imagine what it's like to peanut.
Right.
Pretty much sums it up.
It's true. And at the same time, you know
when, when we're, when the U S is about to
get into a war, maybe we have a point of privilege
there because we know the war is not coming
here. I mean, yes, we deal with individual
terrorist attacks, domestic, most of them,
some, some foreign, but we have a point of
privilege where we can say, do we want to
do a war in this country or not without really
having to worry that the war might actually
be on American soil. And that's an extremely
privileged position to be in.
I, you know, I'm a baby boomer too, and I
think it's terrible that we have to be talking
about Wars. You know, David, what do you think
about a candidate like Marianne Williamson
who comes on a platform of pretty much love?
I know, I realize she doesn't have a chance,
you know, and I was all four-bed Marianne
at the beginning, but now I've switched over
to burning. But what, what do you think of
a candidate like, or somebody like Marianne
Williamson has a chance to ever help turn
this country around?
I love her idea of love. I do. I also find
some of her new age pseudoscience beliefs,
pretty kooky. And last time I mentioned that
people got very mad at me. I've interviewed
her on the program before. She, she has some
ideas that are fine, but you know, she's not
going to be the, she's not going to be elected
in 2020. So let's focus on 2020 first, then
we can figure out what kind of a role may,
maybe Marianne can play in the future.
Oh, okay. Okay, David. Thanks.
All right, my pleasure. Great to hear from
you